tell me
which of these statements apply to you
you have a great need for other people
to like and admire you
you have a tendency to be critical of
yourselves
you have a great deal of unused capacity
which you have not turned to your
advantage
some of your aspirations tend to be
pretty unrealistic
security is one of your major goals in
life
five of the 13 statements that
psychologist Bertram forer presented to
his psychology students in 1949
he told them that the list had been
individually created for each of them
and that they came from a diagnostic
personality Data Bank
called the diagnostic interest blank
but this data Bank didn't exist it was
fake
in truth four came up with this list of
13 so-called personality traits by
pulling them from a newsstand astrology
book
that's right they were randomly chosen
one from each horoscope sign
and every participant in the study
received the exact same 13 items
in what four termed a personality sketch
they were asked to rate the accuracy
of each statement
in a test with 13 random statements the
law of averages suggests that
participants would agree with about half
of the statements or six and a half true
statements for each participant
but that's not what happened here
the average result was closer to 11.
even more remarkable was the fact that
all participants believed that this set
of items was diagnostic meaning that it
was possible to learn something about
themselves from this kind of sketch
they also believed that the tests had
been reasonably accurate and their
personalities had in fact been revealed
except as I mentioned the set of items
was not a diagnostic test nor was it a
personality test
so what led participants to believe the
results so strongly
well it's related to their level of
gullibility being too willing to trust
others or be persuaded to believe that
something's true
and also because of a psychological
concept called self-validation
this is a mental operation that we all
rely on to recognize or validate our
self-worth
it includes accepting things about our
internal experience like our thoughts
and feelings
rather than external experience
self-validation is one way we justify we
matter
and the things we do matter
all human beings have biased Minds
so any justification or validation that
comes from our own minds should be
considered a tad suspect
it's an innate part of how our brains
work but when the forces of
self-validation and gullibility combine
you get the bias we'll be discussing in
this lecture
Four's work in the field has led some
researchers to call this bias the forer
effect
other researchers call it the Barnum
effect yep that Barnum PT Barnum the
circus promoter and showman he's famous
for saying there's a sucker born every
minute and though there's no evidence
you ever said it it's often attributed
to him
psychologist Paul meal coined this bias
the Barnum effect because it appears
when we hear a statement that could be
true of anyone
let's look at one of the items from
Four's experiment
you have a great need for other people
to like and admire you
this seems Broad
of course most people want to be liked
and admired it's vague and that's the
point
how do you get a single statement to
apply to as many people as possible
you make it so vague that everyone says
to themselves oh yeah that sounds like
me
these statements are referred to as
Barnum statements because Barnum knew
how to draw crowds to his shows by using
Broad and generalizable statements that
people would interpret in their own way
and this led them to participate in and
pay for whatever show or product he was
promoting
and this is where the idea of
self-validation comes in
perhaps the fake diagnostic personality
test you got a peek of was just
self-validating it indicated aspects of
your personality didn't it
and when you're validated in this way it
may give you a small boost to your
self-esteem
and it's natural to want to feel good
about yourself
however this bias and the effects of
self-validation from positively worded
statements like the one I just shared
can combine and that gets us into
trouble
fortune tellers astrologers and mediums
often try to make money by simply
telling you Barnum statements and hoping
you'll agree that they apply to you
they'll likely use those same statements
on the client who comes in after you
okay maybe that's not the worst thing in
the world maybe you went to a fortune
teller as a dare or as a goof
maybe you found it entertaining and you
are happy to pay for the fun of the
experience no harm no foul
but what if I told you that this psychic
Services industry is a two billion
dollar one in the U.S alone
that seems like a lot of money for
self-validation or dares
the monetary Stakes can be high
Elizabeth Holmes received millions of
dollars in startup capital for the
health technology company theranos
she stated that her new technology could
revolutionize blood testing with a
single finger prick
here's what she said and see if you can
spot the vagueness
we've created these little tiny tubes
which we call the nanotainers which are
designed to replace the big traditional
tubes that come from your arm and
instead allow for all the testing to be
done from a tiny drop from a finger
there are a couple of Barnum statements
ideas present in that quote
first
what exactly are nanotainers
Marvel Cinematic Universe just putting
the word Quantum in front of anything to
make it sound really cool
I imagine these small tubes aren't
actually Nano sized
another Barnum aspect to this quote
includes the tiny drop from a finger
it's vague
how does all this information come from
a tiny drop of blood
and in the end it was discovered that
was very little truth to her claims and
she was indicted in 2018 for defrauding
investors because the blood tests were
found to be problematic and unable to
perform what was promised to those
investors
ultimately she was found guilty of this
fraud on January 4th 2022.
one of the major cases prosecutors made
against her was that she specifically
targeted powerful donors like former
high-ranking government officials and
Retail executives
Barnum statements can be used to Swindle
folks out of money but they can also be
used to gain power status favors or
prestige
when Prince Harry and Meghan Markle got
married in 2018 an American named Thomas
muscatello convinced several news
outlets he was a son of Kent England and
a British royal expert
he even appeared on the broadcast of
their wedding
muscatello threw on a stereotypical
British accent
spoke about riding horses in the Kent
Countryside and asked an elderly couple
to pose as his grandparents
even his fake last name mace Archer
Mills is an amalgamation of names that
seem generally British
shortly after his appearances on the
wedding broadcasts the Wall Street
Journal completed a background
investigation of Mr muscatello
determining that his actual past didn't
align with his stated past
he has since retreated from public life
people like Holmes and muscatello
managed to fool so many people for so
long
psychologist Ray Hyman defines some of
the techniques that con artists and
hucksters rely on to get you to do what
they want compliance perhaps without
even realizing it's happening
the first thing con artists have is an
air of confidence
all they have to do is believe what
they're doing is real and people will
trust and believe them
next they'll use charts and figures to
make you think that whatever they're
pitching is more reputable than you
might think
they might also employ some sort of
gimmick for example a financial con man
might tell you that they use a
proprietary algorithm to figure out how
to invest your money
a psychic might read your palm or use a
crystal ball
they'll even make sure to know what
you're wearing and reference that in
their schtick
such as commenting on a woman's earrings
or a man's suit
anything to make you feel like the most
important person in the world at that
moment
finally to achieve that importance
they'll use flattery this is one of the
older social influence tricks
I'm sorry to say this but if someone is
flattering you
you might want to think twice about
whether they want something from you or
not
con artists need you to actively go
along with their schemes so flattery is
a perfect technique
all the rest of the stuff I mentioned is
extra Flair because flattery gets your
foot in the door most of the time
but all of that is like I said meant to
make you feel important validated of
course you might think you're important
and so this con artist or huckster is
attempting to highlight that by
validating you
oops there's that word again
you might think I'll never get duped
but these biases and effects are
extremely common and often far more
subtle than the examples I've shared so
far
several replications of fourers
experiment have yielded similar results
there was even a replication where the
items I mentioned at the top of this
lecture were changed to fit
organizations rather than individuals
so instead of you have a great need for
other people to like and admire you it
was your company has a great need to
develop positive brand awareness
participants in this study were leaders
of companies over 800 of them
each answering for their own company
and they showed the same bias that four
found in his students
that is these company leaders the
participants
anthropomorphized gave human qualities
to their companies while evaluating the
sketch
and they agreed with that sketch
overwhelmingly
in other words the participants made
their companies human-like in their own
minds and without prompting and so the
personality sketch seems just like a
person
the results are similar then to what
four found decades before
[Music]
thank you